okay so uh Orlando school boards the
school board in Orlando is trying to ban
furry attire in schools
that difficult watch I can't believe I
have to say this out loud but the furry
dress attire the School dress code Up
For Debate in Brevard County According
to some board members some students are
raising concerns about their classmates
attire they say some kids are dressing
and acting like animals
yeah
no not just a basketball team I was I
was literally like who's gonna do it
sorry I thought that so this is Chicago
it was Fox 35 no this is Orlando oh okay
Brevard County
there are children in our schools that
are dressing as animals um and that
sounds innocent when you say it out loud
uh but there are things but they keep
[__] on the floor like dogs like
it's getting really out of hand it's a
little out of control they keep pumping
the teacher's legs dude this is like
yeah I don't like like Virgie said I
don't understand why this is like
an issue hey you can't be a cat like it
should be simple right yeah but you know
why because they have to let kids be
trans so
then the argument's like why can't I be
a dog
I have a solution to that Royce don't
let the kids be transient yes
don't let kids be anything they're
[__] kids they're morons they can be
quiet yeah
if you're respecting the fetishes of
children your Society dying that's right
thank you that's a [__] Jeff
foxworthyless Alicia's and callers and
walking a child as though they're an
animal and tails that are tripping
hazards yeah they're called furry so I'm
sorry they're banning stuff because this
is a tripping and it's
to be honest with you let me guess this
Matt Susan
you did this you couldn't have better
Optics than being out in a golf course
while this is happening to do this thing
you couldn't Brevard County School Board
Matt Susan yeah why don't you smoke a
cigar while you do this too an anomaly
that I didn't
yeah we just date raped everybody and
[__] slip them roofies back in my day
we had some class simpler times my my
first year of high school we actually
did have this weird [__] that would
like walk on like all floors down the
hallway and hissing people but she was
shunned but she was a teacher
she was a teacher so we couldn't say
anything
Jesus [__] Christ
oh [__]
be clear these board members are not
talking about the full body fursuits you
might see at a convention they believe
accessories like Tails collars or ears
might be distracting to other students
is there they're distracting the schools
by barking and meowing and stuff like
that out of more than 2 000 students oh
my God man they're literally it was not
the most this is the best I love this
actually I think this is hilarious
literally yiffing in school it's a
common issue brought up a spokesperson
for the if virgie's very low it's not my
fault that's on his end guys by the way
I haven't cranked up sorry no it's
[__] it's my bad it's the district
told us they have not seen issues with
students and furry I like that they call
it merge my control Tire
that's pretty funny reports of students
with collars and leashes if you're
telling Elementary School families that
their kids can't emulate a cat or a dog
or a unicorn
you've just eliminated a lot of the
clothes and fun accessories that girls
like to wear at that age you've just
eliminated the clothes and fun
accessories so this woman is I want to
be clear is pro furries profery I never
thought we would have wanted children to
go to school with sexually perverse
demented furries
wow this woman he has no idea what she's
endorsing my dog my daughter wants to be
a pony
Aaron tells us her daughter and many
other students like to wear cat ear
headbands and doesn't see why that's a
problem she thinks behavior is what
needs to be addressed not the attire no
[__] that do you know the [__] you
know rules I had when I went to school
should I go where could wear oh uniforms
and [__] yeah
yeah sorry you can't wear cat ears I
can't believe we had a strict dress go
to most of the schools I went to the
Brevard public school board has so many
issues to tackle I just don't see how
this is even in the top it doesn't
here's the thing more more work on
several things at once yeah do you think
there's only one thing
driving is not the only thing yeah
there's other things okay